- So wait, 'cause of "SNL,"
you've been at 30 Rock quite a bit.
So do you have any advice for me?
I love the building.
- [Sam Jay] The building is dope.
- The whole underground situation.
- Beware of the holidays,
it's gonna make you hate Christmas.
- No, it won't.
- I promise it will.
- I wanna revisit this.
- I have two Christmas albums.
- Okay.
- 'Cause that tree and that traffic.
- Nope.
- It gets crazy.
- I have performed at it several times.
I love Christmas.
- Okay, all right.
- I'm the person that
annoys you and your family.
You're like, "Oh, they're
vomiting Christmas again,
"that's fun."
That's me.
I have a whole village
I set up at my house.
- All right, well maybe you will.
- Okay I'm gonna make it worse here.
No, I love it so much.
But, I heard that you use
men's restrooms if the girls,
you're just like, "No."
- Yeah, that's another
thing I was gonna tell you,
the bathroom on eight
is a good place to poop.
- Okay.
(audience laughing)
- I think that's important
when you work somewhere.
- No, yeah.
(audience laughing and applauding)
It's so hilarious, on our floor,
there's one single
bathroom that you can use
and then there's the one
that community, everybody
and it's the single, you
know what everyone's doing
when they walk in.
I pass by reception.
I'm like that's right.
- Yeah.
- Mama's gotta go.
- I like when the stall
door goes all the way
down to the feet so
people can't see the feet
and they don't know how
long you've been in there.
- Yeah.
- I don't like
when the feet are exposed.
- You have a lot of pressure when you poo.
- [Sam Jay] Yeah, it is.
- I'm just like, "Everybody
does it, I don't care."
Look, you walked in here,
this is where I'm supposed to be doing it.
- It's true.
- Yeah, that's on you.
I'm gonna flush and go.
I'm polite.
I have used men's restrooms though
because when you go to a restaurant,
and I don't care, get mad about it men,
but I am upset because
there's never a line there.
- There's never a line.
- Yeah.
- And it's actually kind of clean.
- And it's cleaner.
'Cause you know why?
Every woman walks in
thinking your nailing it,
there's pee all over the seat.
- Yes, yes, yes.
- It's like,
that's not helpful and if you do that,
you clean it up, ma'am.
- You know what it is though?
With the squat, but what
information out there
is that you've gotta aim.
- Here's the bigger thing.
So has anyone tried to go,
you're welcome America,
they sell you Spanks and they're like,
"Oh man, there's a hole
so it'll make it easier."
- No!
(audience laughing)
- We are so cool.
(Sam Jay laughing)
Watch out for that bathroom
on eight everybody at 30 Rock.